like the truffling just gets to you man
cuz I owe ya like you know when you're
like at university you're like I just
want to travel I want to get get out
want to experience new things but you do
it every year for about a good four
years and it [ __ ] your [ __ ] guess
yeah yeah I think I'm definitely
starting to phase out of that like just
any excuse to travel is correct now I'm
really starting to like to test some
some travel members like when traveling
to anime Khan's was exciting and now the
force of having to go on a plane to get
somewhere that was to be yeah it's it's
a lot harder than it used to be I guess
because it's just of because how it's
become it's always a 10 plus hour flight
and that's like the thing that is really
drink we must sound so god I'm so
annoyed we have to travel so yeah I mean
I guess it happens right when you travel
a shit-ton I'm sure any anyone who has
like parents or family friends who work
their whole business to travel you just
become drinking quick I mean because
it's it is a job at the yeah as I you
know it's people want to travel but if
you've ever had like a office job which
I did for the BBC and got to travel to
Europe you have to travel to these
places and it's just hours and hours of
traveling for the job it drains you no
matter no matter where you're traveling
to if you travel there enough
it'll-it'll
this was a difference between traveling
for pleasure oh yeah I mean like it
doesn't seem it might not seem there's
like a huge difference especially to
someone who doesn't travel a lot but
after a while you're just like man I
have to go no all this flight doses yeah
I get to go on this flight I think the
only time I'm like excited for flight is
one like Netflix drops like a whole show
yeah I'm like super hyped for it's like
yeah sweet like a 10 hours no one bother
me yeah watch this hell yeah that's like
the only time but the worst is when you
get to the Africa like [ __ ] I don't
download any yeah oh no you have to pay
for shitty Wi-Fi to scroll on Twitter
for 12 hours cool I have to play this
solitary game doesn't require any yeah
it's like when you sit down for a [ __ ]
you realize your phones on one percent
I'm like what do I do
what is battery runs the health like
another thing is like time differences
and yeah just asleep I got a question
for you because we went through the same
kind of flight how did you find the
traveling to the crunch rule anime
Awards because to put things in
perspective we we had we were there for
like one day one to two days
yeah and we had to travel how long did
you have to travel 16 ish hours I think
it was for the control anime Awards yeah
21 hours of traveling yeah because
you're in the UK I was in Thailand I was
just even worse yes that was the straw
that broke the camel's back after that I
was like right you know if I'm traveling
too far I I feel like there's got to be
something man okay yeah I'm hanging out
with you after you came back from that
and you were still pissed off about like
that you had to endure that and I'm like
alright well she is cruncher often
experienced I'm sorry I'm trying to be
brand friendly here's my brand